le nouveau champion du monde junior
d'échèque est français il s'agit de Marc
Andria moredi qui a seulement 16 ans a
dominé la compétition des moins de 20
ans gr un départ canon 4/ qu il a mené
la danse jusqu'à son chef-dœuvre lors de
l'AR rond 9F dans la position suivante
avec les pièces blanches il a joué
l'incroyable cavalier D6 et après
l'échange des dames il profite du fait
que son cavalier est tabou puisqu'il
pourrait jouer cavalier B6 intermédiaire
sen prend à la tour qui est défendu par
son homologue qui elle-même défend le
fou et si celle-ci bouge alors les deux
pions blancs passé l EN 6e rangée sont
surpuissants et la stétique ne s'arrête
pas là puisqu'ici les noirs n'ont pas
pris ils ont joué le bon coup fou des TR
et là Marc Andria a joué
l'extraordinaire cavalier B6 se faisant
une autoourchette pour jouer donc sur ce
thème des pions passellers sur la 6e
rangée il a ensuite remporté la finale
et terminé le tournoi invaincu avec 8 et
demi sur 11 il marche ainsi sur les
traces de Joël lotier et Maxime Vacher
La Grave les deux précédents français à
être devenu champion du monde junior
champion du monde